what's going on everybody welcome to
part 4 of our robotics with the
Raspberry Pi tutorial series in this
part we're gonna build on our last
script our last script from tutorial 3
it was the following it just basically
moved our robot forward and back we can
run that again real quick just a really
simple script that just ran it forward
and backwards now what we're gonna do is
create a full kind of user controlled
scenario now in order to do what I want
to do we're gonna need access to the
kind of GUI desktop or what's called X
now there's a couple of ways that we can
do this but the way to do it remotely is
either with a VNC or with something like
X RDP which is sort of a VNC but we can
use that with Windows so Windows isn't
really the most VNC friendly operating
system but with the remote desktop we
can do it really simply so if you're on
Windows what you might be able to do or
get away with is to do sudo apt-get
install XR d MP and run that now I
already have that so nothing's gonna
happen if for some reason it says you
know I cannot find this package or
something's going wrong make sure you
run a sudo apt-get update and also do a
sudo apt-get upgrade and that and then
try to run it one more time otherwise
you you might not be finding your
packages for a different reason now in
this tutorial what we're gonna do first
is I'll wait for this stuff to kind of
go away but once you once you add
actually I can probably connect now but
my processor is probably in use anyway
if you're on Windows and you've
installed xrdp all you do is go to your
Start bar and go to remote desktop
connection if you know if you can't find
it just literally search for a remote
desktop will click on that and up pops
this and then in here is where you put
your local IP address to the Raspberry
Pi now mine's on 193 once you say 0 109
so that's where I'm gonna connect so
I'll hit connect it might be pretty slow
again because the PI is doing stuff but
anyway you'll probably get this a little
you know check thing to see if you
really want to connect to that yes and
then here you'll login
know your information PI raspberry is
probably your password and then you'll
kind of connect it might take a second
again for me because my raspberry PI's
is doing these updates but this will
load and then it basically loads into
the desktop version of the Raspberry Pi
so they'd already have it now you might
actually have a different background
than me I started with a default
raspbian image and I installed the the
go PI goes software but if you started
with the there Dexter industries go PI
go image you probably have a different
background now once you get here we're
going to go ahead and just set this kind
of aside for now but you need to make
sure you can actually achieve this kind
of desktop connection but I'm gonna move
it over for now and now what I'm going
to do is tutorial 3 right click and I'm
just going to duplicate it you can do
whatever you want but I'm just doing
that to make a new file and we'll call
it tutorial 4 dot PI yes you'll probably
enter your password again I didn't I
guess because I have it saved anyway
open up tutorial 4 and now you're ready
to rumble
now what we're gonna do is remove all
this and we're gonna need the following
we ran imports tkinter capital T as TK
and then from go PI go import all again
and in this tutorial we're gonna cover
going forward backwards left/right
rotate stop
grab the distance from the distance
sensor and also move the servo if you
don't have a distance sensor just don't
worry about it don't code that part
right if you don't have the servo don't
worry about it don't code that part
everything else will work just fine so
first we're going to have a little bit
of a constant up here it'll be servo
range and that's going to equal a list
of values 2 3 4 5 6 7 & 8
I'll explain that when we get there to
the to the actual code down at the
bottom now at the very very bottom we're
going to say command equals TK dot T
pay attention to the casing there and
then we're gonna say command dot bind
underscore all and then in quotes here
key with those brackets and then key
underscore inputs okay and then finally
we run commands da main loop you know
all this does is it and this is going to
open up a basic tkinter window and then
it's gonna start tracking all the key
presses that we press and for every key
press that happens it's gonna run key
input with that key event so key input
doesn't exist yet so we're gonna write
the key input function now so we're
going to define key underscore input and
the event we'll just call that literally
event now to find out the key that was
pressed we're going to say key
underscore press equals event key sim or
key symbol dot lower just in case camps
comes into play and then we'll do print
key press like that so we'll go ahead
and save that for now and let me make it
small let's make sure that went over and
then what we'll do is let's bring over
the remote desktop thing now and let's
double click on LX terminal and when
that pops up we need to navigate our way
into the the go PI go local but I'm also
gonna make my font larger so everybody
can see it really well awesome okay so
now LS here CD into desktop go PI go
local list out the stuff there's
tutorial for so I'm gonna go sudo python
tutorial for dot pi hit enter
and hopefully yep there's our tkinter
window now as long as we're active in
this window will click on that and I can
press keys right wsd ad space u or no I
and so on it's a very simple kind of
single key at a time logger
okay so we're that far that was
successful and now what we can do is
assign
oceans when various keys are pressed so
moving this aside well we'll keep
printing the key press just so we can
see it and let's down a little bit so
now that we've got that what we can
start asking is just a bunch of if
statements so we can say if key
underscore press equals W what do we
want to do well we want to run FWD
simple enough then we can go l if key
underscore press equals s what do we
want to do well if it's an S we want to
go backwards so bwd and then we'll keep
this going so I'm instead of typing Elif
and equals all the time I'm just gonna
pace pace pace pace pace paste a few in
there we might not I don't think will
use all of those but it'll save us some
time so we want to handle for WS a d q e
and space and then the letter U and
we'll leave this one for now empty okay
so going back up WS and then a we want
that one not me backward a will be left
D will be right q will be left rot for
left rotate e will be right rott for
right rotate and then the space key will
be to stop woops to stop the bot and
then you will be for the distance sensor
so if you don't have a distance sensor
just get rid of this right but if you
have one we'll use you and the U is just
for ultrasonic distance sensor that's
gonna be the following we'll just we'll
just print it out for now this will just
be the distance so print and then us for
ultrasonic sensor disc and then you give
the pin number if you plugged in the
ultrasonic distance sensor by there
instructions the pin you plugged it into
is probably 15 so there's that now what
we're gonna do is I think we'll just
leave everything now so that should do
for all the things that we need so we'll
save that we'll come down back to our
GUI bring that over here
apparently I am lost on here
I got like off the screen I guess there
we go
rerun that and then the tkinter window
should pop up there it is
and then now let's just try forward
command so you should see that the
wheels on mine are spinning and yours
should be spinning - let's try backwards
sure enough now it's going backwards
let's try a rotate so I'll hit Q and
then now they should be spinning in
opposite directions let's try E now they
should spin in the other opposite
direction now let's try stop this thing
space cool so now we can actually
remote-control our lap our front laptop
remote control R go PI go with our
keyboard now before we go on to the next
tutorial I do want to show the servo as
well so what I will do and if you don't
have a servo then you can pretty much
just jump to the next tutorial but if
you do have a servo or you want to know
how we're gonna handle for the servo
here's all we would do it's pretty quick
code so we're gonna say L if ki
underscore press dot is digit because
the key press is coming through as a
string but what you can do to find out
if a string is actually a number that's
in a string format you can just ask is
digit that it's bullying so it comes
through is either true or false so if
you've got if the did if the you know
the string is 5 and you say if five dot
is digit even though it's a string it's
gonna come back as a true because yes 5
is a digit so if the key press is a
digit the next thing that we're gonna
ask is if int if the integer value of
the key press is in our wall underscore
range we're gonna enable the servo so
otherwise it's not going to be
and then we're gonna go we're gonna say
servo and then we basically want to set
the servo and you set it to a value and
this value is going to be the integer
value of the key press times 14 this
just worked out from my servo it just
seemed like a good number and basically
this will be to the point where five
times 14 so 70 is the center point
basically for the servo about depends on
how well you screw the servo in mine was
a little crooked so your number might be
a little different but you do that and
then two to eight will be kind of
sweeping motion and again depending on
how well you hooked up your serve on how
long your camera if you have a camera on
there my main issue is that the camera
cord basically is not very long so if
you rotate all the way over in one
direction you basically run on a camera
cord and you're pulling on that cord and
so I don't want to do that but if you
don't have a camera you can actually
rotate this thing around quite a bit
anyway we set the server to that number
and then we'll go ahead and disable the
servo now yours might be a little
different I don't know but for some
reason I just enable the servo set the
servo and disable it because the servo
like it'll just keep kind of like
wiggling a little bit if you don't
disable it so I disabled it to shut it
up and stop it from wiggling so much but
I think part of that is because there's
a little bit of resistance that it's
coming from that camera module so I
think that's why it's doing it so
disabling it seems to help a lot but
again yours might differ from mine so
anyways we'll save this and I'm actually
done there so I'm going to move that out
of the way and let this log my my key
anyway we're gonna close this and have
to rerun it so it's running the new
version of tutorial 4 okay so now it's
up we can go forward stop and then now
you can start pressing your cert or your
buttons for the servo range and you
should see that the servo actually moves
now we probably should have added a
slight time because now like like this
is two and then eight I'm pressing eight
but it takes a few presses to get it
over so actually maybe what we might
want to do
is give it a slight sleep maybe time not
sleep one just try that real quick I'm
not sure that it can't remember if the
servo will just keep running or not but
we'll find out in a moment
so that pops up let's try two yeah there
we go so eight five now that yes so with
that one second that's enough time for
it to actually get to the point where it
wants to be and then you can actually I
can hear it you probably can't hear it
on the mic but I can hear it kind of
wiggling and then it's disabled and
shuts up but anyway so now you can
control the servo position with your
keyboard so that's pretty cool
so anyways that's that for this tutorial
now we're able to control a robot and
move forward backward I pressed way too
many keys it's going crazy forward
backward rotate we never checked the
distance so I'll hit you and now you can
see the distance is 677 centimeters from
the point of fire which is going
basically all the way across my room so
yeah that makes a lot of sense so that's
it for the basic control of your cope I
go in the next tutorial we're going to
be talking about controlling the missile
launcher on our go PI go so that'll be
very exciting if you have any questions
or comments up to this point please feel
free to leave them below otherwise as
always thanks for watching things for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time